in the past after Donald Trump has made
indefensible false claims about you know
Obama wasn't born in the US or Obama
wiretapped me Trump would be in
interviews and the interviewer would try
to ask him for evidence of the claims
and try to see whether Trump still
believes these claims and very often
Trump would just try to steer the
conversation in another Direction saying
oh that's an old subject or you'll found
out find out from someone else or no one
cares about that or something like that
like for example when John Dickerson was
interviewing Donald Trump in the Oval
Office not long ago and asked about the
Obama wiretapped me claims and Trump
abruptly ended the interview and kicked
Dickerson out of his office those
situations always seem like they sort of
should be really embarrassing for Donald
Trump if it's even possible for Trump to
be embarrassed last week just a few days
after Trump fired FBI director James
Comey Trump had yet another one of these
weird defensive outbursts on Twitter we
covered this yesterday where Donald
Trump tweeted James Comey better hope
that there are no quote tapes of our
conversations before he starts leaking
to the Press Trump has tweeted endless
asinine things over the years including
while he's been in office as the
president he's had to put his foot in
his mouth many times sometimes it's lies
sometimes it's an immature rant but this
is actually one of the most serious and
bold claims that Trump has made on
Twitter it was it was basically a threat
to James Comey right does Trump think he
can just tweet whatever he wants as long
as he puts certain words and quotes
Obama quote wiretapped me James Comey
better not have any hope there are no
tapes quote tapes is this some kind of
tip maybe Trump got from a lawyer you
put these words in quotes it's like he's
trying to distance himself from the
allegation but the thing is if there are
tapes Trump would be the one to know
about them right that's why he's bring
them up in the first place so all of a
sudden Trump gets asked about the tapes
in an interview with Fox News is Janine
Piro suddenly he doesn't want to talk
about the tapes anymore right after he
posted the Tweet the White House refused
to confirm or deny whether the tapes
exist Spicer the press secretary Shan
Spicer completely stonewalled during a
press briefing and when Trump sat down
for an interview with Fox News uh uh
anchor host whatever Janine Piro Trump
Flatout refuses to discuss the existence
of the tapes take a look at this what
about the idea that in a tweet you said
that there might be tape recordings well
that I can't talk about I won't talk
about that all I want is for com to be
honest and I hope he will be and I'm
sure he will be I hope okay and so let
this new director of the FBI yeah let's
talk about the new director so of course
Fox News doesn't press him on it at all
moving right along to the next question
uh in spite of the fact that what you
you tweeted would be a blockbuster if it
were true so just like with many of
other Trump's uh Trump's outrageous
assertions he again makes it never
presenting evidence to begin with and
then avoids being held accountable for
the statement when he's asked about it
the cat is out of the bag here if you
don't want to talk about that why did
you choose to tweet it to the entire
world it's just such a dumb thing to say
because if there are tapes then they can
be susp subpoena by the Democrats who
are conducting an investigation against
him and if there aren't tapes then that
removes any leverage he would claim to
have over James Comey so there's only a
third option there which is to not
conform or deny the existence of them
and to try to sort of glean some benefit
from the possibility that maybe they
exist but as you're pointing out what
would that benefit be if you don't
actually have the goods it's so
ridiculous that even prominent
Republicans are calling Trump out on
this Lindsey Graham who's a Republican
senator from South Carolina said over
the weekend quote you can't be be cute
about tapes if there are any tapes of
this conversation they need to be turned
over and I doubt if there are if the
tapes exist they would be of much
interest to the many committees and
agencies investigating the Trump Russia
connections any recordings related to
the firing of James Comey could be
evidence that indicates whether Donald
Trump criminally obstructed Justice in
the investigation and if the tapes are
real if any of Trump's statements or
actions regarding the firing of James
Comey constitute anything like
obstruction of justice this may be the
closest that we've ever gotten to a
material Prospect of an impeachment of
Donald Trump but these are all really
really big ifs Congressional Democrats
and Republicans are saying that the
tapes if they exist should and will be
subpoena I saw an interview today with
one of the lawyers that was involved in
the Watergate scandal he made it pretty
clear that it's not going to be an easy
Tas ask to subpoena those tapes even if
they do exist so this is something we're
going to be watching very very closely
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman send me your
thoughts about this the show is on
Twitter at David Pacman show